We're gonna we're gonna now call Bryce Dr. Doolittle here because I like like like I legitimately would like to own a horse now and go riding on said horse. Welcome to ADSP the podcast episode, recorded on June 4th, 2022. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we respond to Reddit comments on episode 80, where we talked about GPUs and multidimensional iterators. So my girlfriend's dog, we got spayed yesterday. Thoughts and prayers go out to the dog. was that we got her a dog bed for my apartment, which I'm very excited about because the spot she likes in my apartment is right under my desk.
我们现在要叫布莱斯“杜立德医生”，因为我现在真的想拥有一匹马，然后去骑那匹马。欢迎收听ADSP播客，录制于2022年6月4日。我是康纳，今天我的联合主持人是布莱斯，我们在第80期节目中回复了红迪网上的评论，在那期节目中我们讨论了GPU和多维迭代器。所以，我女朋友的狗，我们昨天给它做绝育手术了。在此向这只狗致以思想和祈祷。我们在我的公寓里给她买了一个狗床，我对此非常兴奋，因为她在我的公寓里最喜欢的位子正好在我的书桌下面。
And that dog bed is just very comfortable for my feet. Like I'm very, very happy with this setup. You know, having like a warm dog there to keep my feet warm is like also a benefit yeah i didn't think that was where that was going but where did you think that was going i thought you were going to say that you were unhappy um because this is good we could lose a couple listeners here but i am not the biggest dog fan fan. I do know this based upon some past conversations you and I have had. And to redeem myself a little bit, I actually do love dogs. I just don't like untrained dogs, which happens to be the majority of dogs.
而且那个狗床对我的脚来说非常舒服。就像我对这个设置感到非常非常高兴一样。你知道，那里有一只温暖的狗来暖我的脚也是一个好处。是的，我没想到会这样发展。但你以为会怎么发展？我以为你会说你很不高兴。嗯，因为这很好，我们可能会失去几个听众，但我不是最大的狗粉。我根据你我过去的一些对话知道这一点。为了稍微挽回一点面子，我其实真的很喜欢狗。我只是不喜欢未经训练的狗，而这恰好是大多数狗的情况。
And if you're a dog owner and you're like, well, my dog's trained. If, for instance, I'm in an elevator and you are also in that elevator with your dog and you think that we're losing a couple listeners here. And you think that, oh, everyone loves dogs. I'll just let my dog jump all over this person and start licking his pants and blah, blah, blah. To me, that is an untrained dog or maybe an untrained owner that thinks that like their dog is the world's greatest gift, et cetera, et cetera. I love all dogs and I am completely fine with your dogs jumping on me in elevators and other places. I'm also very good with dogs. Yeah, like Olivier Gouraud's dogs love me.
如果你是一个养狗人士，心里想，好吧，我的狗受过训练。例如，如果我在电梯里，你也在电梯里带着你的狗，你觉得我们在这里要失去一些听众了。你觉得，哦，每个人都喜欢狗。我就让我的狗扑到这个人身上，开始舔他的裤子，巴拉巴拉。对我来说，那是一只未经训练的狗，或者可能是一个未经训练的主人，他们认为自己的狗是世界上最好的礼物，等等，等等。我喜欢所有的狗，我完全不介意你的狗在电梯和其他地方往我身上跳。我也很擅长与狗相处。是的，比如奥利维尔·古罗的狗就很喜欢我。
Those dogs love me because I give the best belly rubs. Like we go, we go, we go months without seeing each other, but then I see his dogs again and they remember me because they remember how much I love them. This is, this is extremely true because one time the both of us went over to, um, Olivier's house for dinner and yeah those dogs absolutely they were like oh our our kindred spirit has arrived um and like the dogs were just laying their lap in their heads in your lap and yeah yeah so yeah definitely bryce is the dog person of the two of us i'm i'm good i'm great with too. Don't tell the girlfriend that she does not like cats. But yeah, I'm just I'm just an animal whisperer. I'm good. I'm good with horses, too, apparently, because when we were in Utah, we did horseback riding, which I've never done before. And I thought it was going to be scary. But no, apparently I am a natural with horses, too. And I now love horses.
那些狗喜欢我，因为我能提供最好的挠肚皮服务。我们彼此不见面好几个月，但当我再次看到他的狗时，它们还记得我，因为它们记得我有多爱它们。这是极其真实的，因为有一次我们俩去奥利维尔家吃晚饭，是的，那些狗绝对表现得就像“哦，我们的知己来了”，那些狗就把头枕在你的大腿上，是的，是的。所以，绝对的，布莱斯是我们两个里面更喜欢狗的那个人。我很擅长，我跟……太棒了。别告诉女朋友，她不喜欢猫。但是，是的，我只是一个动物悄悄话专家。我很好。显然我对马也很好，因为我们在犹他州的时候，我们骑过马，我以前从来没骑过。我以为这会很吓人。但并没有，显然我对马也很有天赋。我现在爱上马了。
We're going to we're going to now callryce dr doolittle here because uh i like like like i legitimately would like to own a horse now and go riding on said horse i mean i could see that for you i could see you having like a ranch that you visit on weekends or like live on a house on the ranch and have people to look after the horses and then visiting that part of your property on the weekends yeah did you did you see these pictures of the dog mugging that i oh yeah yeah those were great those were great um i thought that really added a lot a lot of color to um to the story there were there were a few that were even better which was my girlfriend like trying to shoo them out out of but i could not um tweet those because she was in her pajamas
我们现在要叫布莱斯“杜立德医生”，因为……嗯，我喜欢……我真的想现在拥有一匹马，去骑那匹马。我的意思是，我能想象你这样。我能想象你有一个周末去参观的牧场，或者住在牧场上的房子里，让人照顾马匹，然后在周末参观你财产的那一部分。是的，你看到那些关于狗扒小偷的照片了吗？哦，是的，那些太棒了，那些太棒了。我觉得这真的为故事增添了很多色彩。还有一些甚至更好，就是我女朋友试图把它们赶出去，但我不能发那些推特，因为她穿着睡衣。
and I determined that she would murder me if I tweeted those pictures. Well, maybe if we ever start like a Patreon podcast model where we charge our listeners for the juiciest content, which don't worry, listener, we're never going to do that.
我确信如果我把那些照片发到推特上，她会谋杀了我的。好吧，也许如果我们开始某种Patreon播客模式，向我们的听众收取最有肉容的内容——不过别担心，听众朋友，我们永远不会那样做。
You mean an OnlyFans. You're describing i mean that's not what all the other podcasts call it but sure i mean it is kind of the same transactional model um yeah where you're paying money for a certain type of content um but uh anyways to to bring it back to where i thought your story was going because that's where this all started. I'm not a big fan of dogs. So when you were talking about the dog being under your desk, my first thought was obviously Bryce does not want that dog there. And so that he's happy that
你是说OnlyFans。你在描述……我的意思是，虽然不是所有其他播客都这么叫，但当然，我的意思是，这有点像那种交易模式，嗯，你花钱买某种类型的内容。但是，无论如何，回到我以为你的故事会怎么发展的地方，因为这一切都是从这里开始的。我不是狗的超级粉丝。所以当你谈到那只狗在你的书桌下时，我的第一反应显然是布莱斯不希望那只狗在那里。所以他很高兴
he's getting this bed so that he can put the bed somewhere else. So the dog will no longer want to go under the desk, you know, win-win um and then when you said uh and it's fantastic because it's very fluffy and it makes my feet comfortable i was like damn i got that one wrong um regardless of whether or not you own a dog i i highly recommend that everybody go get a dog bed to put your feet on when you're sitting at your work desk because it's amazing and then once you've got the dog bed you may as well get a dog too so yeah but if you thought that i was if i was unhappy with anything that my girlfriend's dog was doing do you think that i would mention it here in a place that she could theoretically have access to i mean you did say last episode that uh or is it two episodes ago that she
他得到了这个床，这样他就可以把床放在别的地方。这样狗就不会再想钻到书桌底下了，双赢啊。然后当你说“太棒了，因为它非常蓬松，让我的脚很舒服”时，我就想：天哪，我猜错了。不管你有没有养狗，我强烈建议每个人都去买一个狗床，当你坐在办公桌前时把脚放在上面，因为这太棒了。然后一旦你有了狗床，你不妨也养一只狗。所以，是的，如果你以为我对女朋友的狗做的任何事情都不满意，你觉得我会在这里，在一个她理论上可以访问的地方提及它吗？我的意思是，你在上一集里确实说过，或者那是两集之前，她说
neither she nor your mother listens so yes yes um those are both true points but I'm I'm I'm well I guess we're on apple podcast so my mother could get access yeah she she doesn't my my mother does not have the attention span to put up with all of the the the tech nonsense and random weird tangents that we have to get far enough to to hear any of the things that she may take offense at it's true it's true even when even when there's like non-technical episodes sometimes i'll send them to my family and no one listens because they just don't care. They're like, Connor, we hear your voice enough when you come by like one week out of the year. That's way too much already. It's not actually entirely true about my mother.
她和你的母亲都不听，所以是的，是的。嗯，这两点都是真的，但我猜我们在苹果播客上，所以我母亲可以访问。是的，她不……我母亲没有那么长的注意力去忍受所有的技术废话和我们那些随机的怪异旁支，以至于无法听到任何她可能会觉得被冒犯的事情。这是真的，这是真的。即使当……即使有时有非技术的节目，有时我会把它们发给我的家人，也没有人听，因为他们根本不在乎。他们会说：“康纳，当你一年来一次的时候，我们听到你的声音已经够多了。这已经太多了。”关于我母亲，其实这并不完全正确。
Throughout my career, my mother has tried very hard to understand what it is exactly that I do. So she might have this game but i just i just don't i think that if she did she would start at episode zero i don't think she would start at the latest episodes or like even if she did like like like she's in italy right now so i wouldn't need to worry about her listening to like like this particular episode but she might get through some of them. I do not think she would get through any episodes. That's true.
在我的职业生涯中，我母亲一直非常努力地想要理解我到底在做什么。所以她可能会有这个游戏，但我只是……我只是觉得，如果她听的话，她会从第0集开始。我不认为她会从最新的节目开始，或者甚至如果她真的这样做的话……她现在在意大利，所以我不需要担心她听这一集特定的节目，尽管她可能会听完其中一些。我不认为她能听完任何一集。这是真的。
Prove me wrong, mom. Prove me wrong. Maybe one day we'll release like the most technically titled episode and then we'll just talk about like the juiciest gossip, like family gossip and hope that none of our families listen to it.
证明我错了，妈妈。证明我错了。也许有一天我们会发布一个技术性最强的剧集标题，然后我们只谈论最香的八卦，比如家庭八卦，并希望我们的家人都不听它。
Anyways, we need to get back to these these so you've been waiting for a week for us to talk about these reddit comments and uh i'm gonna read the first one connor edited this together in a way that did not no like i did not i just cut it straight in half i read some other reddit comments where people were talking about what podcasts would replace CPPcast. And there were some people who suggested ours. And there were some people who were like, yeah, but like half the time they just go off on tangents. That's true. And Bryce is too.
无论如何，我们需要回到这些……所以你已经等了一个星期让我们谈论这些红迪网的评论，我要读第一篇。康纳把这个剪辑在一起的方式并没有……不，像我没有，我只是把它直接切成两半。我读了一些其他的红迪网评论，人们在讨论什么播客会取代CPPcast。有些人建议我们的节目。还有些人说，是的，但是他们有一半时间都在扯闲篇。这是真的。布莱斯也太……
Oh, God. What was the word? It wasn't demure. It was another word. Nonchalant. Bryce is too nonchalant on the podcast. Nonchalant. Bryce is too nonchalant on the podcast. Nonchalant? Yes, which is a very true assessment, I think.
哦，天哪。那个词是什么？不是温顺（demure）。是另一个词。冷漠（nonchalant）。布莱斯在播客里太冷漠了。冷漠。布莱斯在播客里太冷漠了。冷漠？是的，我认为这是一个非常真实的评价。
We're supposed to be – I don't know what the opposite of nonchalant – I know what nonchalant means, but I don't think chalant is a word. But like this is – listen, listen. I'm all about constructive criticism, whoever made that comment. But this is our podcast. No, chalant is a word. Is chalant a word? But, well, no, no, no, I don't think it's a real word. Wiktionary defines it as not non-chalant, which is about the dumbest definition i've ever heard i mean um i think that's the that's the
我们本该是——我不知道冷漠的反义词是什么——我知道冷漠是什么意思，但我不认为chalant这个词存在。但是，听着，听着。不管是谁发表的评论，我都全盘接受建设性的批评。但这是我们的播客。不，chalant是个词。Chalant是个词吗？但是，不，不，不，我不认为这是一个真正的词。Wiktionary（维基词典）将其定义为“不冷漠”，这是我听过的最蠢的定义。我的意思是……我认为这就是……
beauty of uh our podcast i mean that's the thing is i kind of thought that like it's a real shame that cpp cast disappeared because they're kind of in my mind like this kind of like voice or like core where you know a couple news articles that's a good c++ podcast you know what the one that like the actual the actual quality podcast yeah yeah they they they have like a format as to whatever this is yeah we are not that and that's the thing i was like should we start doing like a couple news articles and then my first thought was just like no like that's i don't want to do that uh we if we did we'd have to start another podcast for that purpose. Not this one.
我们播客的美妙之处。我的意思是，这就是问题所在，我曾经觉得，CPPcast消失真是一个遗憾，因为在我的心目中，它们就像是这样一种声音或核心，你知道的，有几篇新闻报道，这是一个好的C++播客。你知道的，那个像真正的、真正高质量的播客，是的，是的。他们有一种格式，不管是什么。是的，我们不是那样。这就是问题所在，我当时想，我们应该开始做几篇新闻报道吗？然后我的第一反应是：不，这就是……我不想那样做。如果我们那样做，我们就得为了那个目的开另一个播客。而不是这个。
I like the fact that we got three minutes into our last episode 81 and we were like, all right, we're going to talk about Topic X. And then I was like, oh, wait a second. We got to do some corrections. And now that I've said that. Yeah, I was going to stop you. I was like, what, what are you doing? Like.
我喜欢我们在上一集（第81集）开始三分钟后就说：“好吧，我们要讨论话题X。”然后我就说：“哦，等一下，我们得做一些更正。”现在我已经说过了。是的，我本打算阻止你的。我当时想：“你在干什么？就像……”
Technically, I won't go read the other one, but that was only one thing I needed to mention. There's a list of them, but we'll do that on another episode. And Bryce still has to go to the gym. And Bryce still has to go to the gym. And eat food. But anyways, go on. Listen, the nonchalant list is here to stay, even though I don't think that's the right word. Nonchalant is kind of like adjacent to—
严格来说，我不会去读另一个，但那只是我需要提到的一件事。有一个列表，但我们会在另一集里做这个。布莱斯还得去健身房。布莱斯还得去健身房。还要吃东西。不过，不管怎样，继续吧。听着，“冷漠列表”会一直都在，尽管我不认为那是正确的词。冷漠有点类似于……
They didn't say you were nonchalant they said i was nonchalant but doesn't doesn't nonchalant it's i i think it's adjacent to like apathetic it's like you know you're not you know yeah yeah i don't you think you're nonchalant on this i think you get overwhelmingly excited and blow people's eardrums out with your i am sufficiently seasoned that I have learned to not care about a number of things that I deem not sufficiently important. Whereas you – maybe it's not seasoned. I'm traumatized enough. No, that's not the right word. I've seen enough things.
他们没说你冷漠，他们说我冷漠。但是，冷漠难道不……我，我认为它类似于冷漠（apathetic），就像你知道的，你不是……你知道的，是的，是的。你不觉得你在这上面很冷漠吗？我觉得你总是压倒性地兴奋，用你的声音把人们的耳膜震破……我是足够成熟，已经学会不在乎我认为不够重要的许多事情。而你——也许不是成熟。我已经够受创伤的了。不，那不是正确的词。我已经见过足够多的事情了。
I've seen enough things that like, I have learned to be like, yeah, you know, I don't really care about that, that particular thing. Whereas you, you're just like, you're like, uh, a young school girl. You're just always so excited by the world and the the singing of the birds the blossoming flowers you gotta stop to smell every rose and i'm just like yeah whatever like let's get to the important things here so yes all right it's a fair criticism i don't i don't know how to take being called a young school girl but um sure i'll take it as a compliment anyways we're like 20 minutes into our 30-minute episode talking about comments on episode 80. In episode 82, here's our first comment from James Barrow. Hopefully, I'm pronouncing that correctly. The discussion
我已经见过足够多的事情，以至于我学会了说：“是的，你知道，我真的不在乎那件特定的事情。”而你，你就像……你就像一个年轻的女学生。你总是对世界、鸟儿的歌唱、盛开的花朵感到如此兴奋。你得停下来闻闻每一朵玫瑰，而我只是想：“是的，随便吧——让我们谈谈重要的事情。”所以，是的，好吧，这是一个公平的批评。我不知道被叫做年轻的女学生该作何感想，但……当然，我就当它是赞美了。无论如何，我们已经进入30分钟节目的20分钟了，还在讨论第80集的评论。在第82集里，这里是我们的第一条评论，来自詹姆斯·巴罗。希望我没有发错音。讨论
around GPU iteration order feels a little like something's being lost in translation. If you have a 2D array in row major order and you want it to some column-wise, each thread will be assigned to one element in a row and then iterate down columns. So if you consider the thread index to be your loop variable, it's not all that different. The mismatch here, I suspect, is actually in the definition of a thread. GPU threads are essentially one lane in a SIMD architecture. That's S-I-M-D. So I think the mix up here is essentially definition in nature. In a CPU architecture, you'd give each thread a chunk of data to process, loading rightwards slash contiguously slash row-wise with SIMD, and then summing downwards, which isn't different to a GPU.
围绕GPU迭代顺序的讨论感觉有点像在翻译中迷失了某些东西。如果你有一个按行优先顺序排列的2D数组，并且你想按列求和，每个线程将被分配到一行中的一个元素，然后向下迭代各列。因此，如果你把线程索引视为循环变量，其实并没有那么大差异。我怀疑这里的错位实际上是对线程的定义。GPU线程本质上是SIMD架构中的一个通道（lane）。也就是S-I-M-D。所以我认为这里的混淆本质上是定义上的。在CPU架构中，你会给每个线程分配一块数据来处理，使用SIMD向右/连续/按行加载，然后向下求和，这与GPU没有什么不同。
It's just a terminological, it's terminological at that point. In a language like OpenCL, running on a CPU, each thread maps to one SIMD lane, and it's very much like programming a GPU. He's absolutely right, but it, every lane is an independent threat. And now with modern NVIDIA GPUs, truly an independent threat. this sort of joined vector style execution for operations where all the threads are at the same place and doing the same thing, the way that you write the code is different from how you'd write the code on the CPU. And as Olivier used to describe it,
这只是一种术语上的，在这一点上是术语上的。在像OpenCL这样在CPU上运行的语言中，每个线程映射到一个SIMD通道，这非常类似于编程GPU。他是完全正确的，但它……每个通道都是一个独立的线程。而现在有了现代NVIDIAGPU，真正成为了一个独立的线程。这种用于操作的联合向量式执行，即所有线程都在同一个地方做同一件事，你编写代码的方式与在CPU上编写代码的方式是不同的。正如奥利维尔过去常描述的那样，
you know, the GPU compiler, in the GPU compiler, we vectorize so late, we vectorize in the hardware. And, you know, the difference in the programming model does change how you write the code. Like under the hood, yeah, like the code is, you know, the way that you optimally process things may be the same but the way that you write the code and the way that you logically
你知道，GPU编译器，在GPU编译器中，我们向量化得非常晚，我们在硬件中进行向量化。而且，你知道，编程模型的不同确实改变了你编写代码的方式。就像在底层，是的，代码是……你以最优方式处理事物的方式可能是相同的，但你编写代码的方式以及你在每个线程中逻辑上
move through the data and the code in each thread is a bit different awesome well james barrow you heard it here you're 100 correct but that that doesn't mean programming to each of these, a GPU and a CPU, is the same. Moving on to comment number two. I think James was the best comment. But yeah, we will move on to comment number two. Really enjoyed. This is from Kemanachi.
遍历数据和代码的方式有点不同。太棒了，詹姆斯·巴罗，你在这里听到了，你100%正确。但这并不意味着为其中每一个编程——GPU和CPU——是相同的。接下来是评论二。我觉得詹姆斯的是最好的评论。但是，是的，我们会转到评论二。非常喜欢。这是来自Kemanachi的评论。
Don't know who that is because it's Reddit. Really enjoyed this episode. A lot of the multidimensional reordering just sounded like flattening a matrix, quote unquote, to me. I believe APL calls it raising a matrix. I think raising is J terminology. APL calls it raveling, but same difference. Also, the way Bryce described how GPUs work sounded pretty intuitive. I think a great diagram or animated visual might help clearing that up within the array
不知道那是谁，因为这是红迪网。非常喜欢这一集。对我来说，很多多维重排听起来就像把矩阵“扁平化”，引号。我记​​得APL称之为提升矩阵。我想“提升”是J语言的术语。APL称之为拉韦尔（raveling/降维），但大同小异。此外，布莱斯描述GPU工作方式的方式听起来相当直观。我认为一个出色的图表或动画视觉效果可能有助于在数组语言社区中澄清这一点。
language community. This episode has me even more interested in seeing how MD-SPAN and multidimensional iterators will work on GPUs in the future. Comments? I'm not sure I understand the flattening part. I mean, it is certainly true that I think almost all ways of performing operations on multidimensional structures do tend to lead to some flattening, you know, in some way, shape, or form. And by that, I mean that sort of we, you know, you move through in some sequence in time through the data. And like that is like a linear thing um that you do um
这一集让我对未来MD-SPAN和多维迭代器将如何在GPU上工作更加感兴趣。有何评论？我不确定我是否理解扁平化部分。我的意思是，我确信，几乎所有对多维结构执行操作的方法确实往往会导致某种扁平化，你知道的，以某种形状或形式。我的意思是，我们，你知道的，你在时间上按某种顺序穿过数据。这就像是你做的一件线性事情。
but i'm not sure that i understand the flatten where what he's talking about the flattening in this context so flattening i mean i think what he's probably referring to is when you describe the two different um ways you can index yeah when dealing with the 2d matrix the first one was just uh or i can't remember if it was first or second but one of them was just yeah yeah it was just you know looping from zero to uh your dimensions time your dimensions and then doing some modulus arithmetic that in a sense is basically just looping from if you if you're storing your array contiguously in memory, just like from the beginning to the end, and then behind the scenes,
但我不太明白在这个语境下他所说的扁平化是什么意思。所以扁平化，我的意思是，我想他可能指的是当你描述两种不同的……你可以索引的方法时，是的。在处理二维矩阵时，第一个只是……或者我记不清是第一个还是第二个，但其中一个只是……是的，是的，它只是，你知道的，从零循环到……你的维度乘以你的维度，然后做一些模数运算。从某种意义上说，这基本上就是循环，如果你把数组连续存储在内存中，就像从头到尾一样，然后在幕后，
you're doing some modulus arithmetic to get I and J. Yeah, exactly. Yeah. And like, as we discussed in that episode, that approach is usually not the right way to do things. Yeah. yeah yeah because that that the the there's information loss when you go from a from you know a multi-dimensional position to a linear index into storage um there's information loss you can reconstruct the multi-dimensional index from the linear location in storage but that's often an expensive operation. And that's maybe something that we didn't get into in the last time. And this is sort of something that's
你做一些模数运算来得到I和J。是的，完全正确。是的。而且，正如我们在那一集里讨论过的，这种方法通常不是做事的最正确方式。是的，是的，是的。因为当从多维位置转换到存储中的线性索引时，会发生信息丢失。存在信息丢失。你可以从存储中的线性位置重建多维索引，但这通常是一个昂贵的操作。这可能是我们在上次没有深入探讨的内容。这也是某种程度上
core to the MD-SPAN model. An MD-SPAN, this is core to a lot of like matrix models, but MD-SPAN illustrates it particularly well because an MD-SPAN is a non-owning view into something. So when you construct an MD-SPAN, you give it a pointer to some data somewhere. In the MD-SPAN model, that data is just a linear data. It's not inherently multidimensional indices, from some multidimensional space, into single-dimensional indices into that storage. And that storage array, it may be contiguous, it may not be contiguous.
MD-SPAN模型的核心。在MD-SPAN中，这是许多矩阵模型的核心，但MD-SPAN将其阐释得特别好，因为MD-SPAN是对某事物的非拥有性视图（non-owning view）。因此，当你构造一个MD-SPAN时，你给它一个指向某处数据的指针。在MD-SPAN模型中，该数据只是线性数据。它本质上不是多维索引，不是从某个多维空间到该存储的单维索引。那个存储数组可能是连续的，也可能是不连续的。
In a lot of the simple cases, you can think of it being contiguous, but if you're, or you can think of the, let me rephrase that, the backing storage is contiguous, but the elements that the order of the elements that you might access may not be a mapping from not every element in that contiguous block of storage may be mapped to from one of the multidimensional indices. But so you have this operation in MD-SPAN that's defined by the layout, which is the operation where you give it a multidimensional index and it gives you back a single dimensional index, which is the location and storage.
在许多简单的案子里，你可以认为它是连续的，但如果你是……或者你可以认为……让我重新措辞一下，底层存储是连续的，但是你可能访问的元素的顺序可能不是一种映射——该连续存储块中的并非每个元素都可以从其中一个多维索引映射到。因此，你在MD-SPAN中拥有这个由布局（layout）定义的操作，即你给它一个多维索引，它会返回给你一个单维索引，这就是在存储中的位置。
And so when you're iterating, your iterator can choose to store one of those two things, either the multidimensional index, the thing that you would give to this layout function, or the storage index. And the problem is that the layout function that does this mapping is usually pretty quick. There are some cases like sparse where it may be more expensive, but let's just assume that it's pretty quick. Especially in dense cases, it's almost always pretty quick. But the inverse operation of that going from storage index to multidimensional index, that's almost always slow. And at the very least, it's almost always slower than the other way around. And so it's almost always wrong to store the storage index in discard the multidimensional index if you ever think that you're going to need to reconstruct and reuse that multidimensional index.
因此，当你进行迭代时，你的迭代器可以选择存储这两者之一：要么是多维索引（你会传给这个布局函数的东西），要么是存储执行索引。问题在于，进行这种映射的布局函数通常相当快。有些情况比如稀疏数组（sparse）可能会比较昂贵，但我们假设它相当快。尤其是在密集数组（dense）的情况下，它几乎总是相当快的。但是从存储索引回到多维索引的逆操作，几乎总是很慢。而且至少，它几乎总是比反过来要慢。因此，如果你认为你需要重建并重用该多维索引，去存储存储索引并丢弃多维索引几乎总是错误的。
Yeah, we're probably going to end up having a bunch of conversations around this topic based on where my career is going. Because I've been thinking about this ever since starting to work at NVIDIA, which was now back in 2019. Is that we have a, like, and this is getting very NVIDIA specific. So, you know, I apologize to the listener if you care less about this topic. But there's a bunch of different, and some of it is C++. But like, so C++, MD-SP md span and md array are coming and in terms of the libraries that nvidia offers there's like a a bunch of different like we've got kublas
是的，根据我的职业生涯走向，我们最终可能会围绕这个话题进行一堆对话。因为自从2019年开始在NVIDIA工作以来，我一直在思考这个问题。也就是说，我们有一个……这变得非常NVIDIA特定。所以，如果听众对这个话题不太关心，我向听众道歉。但这里有很多不同的东西，其中一部分是C++。比如，C++的MD-SPAN、md span和md array即将到来，就NVIDIA提供的库而言，有一堆不同的……我们有kublas
we've got matx we've got you know python front ends to c++ backends that are sort of you know numpy copies and i've always wondered uh like what's actually like the most efficient backend to a kind of like array language? Because, you know, all the indexing that you're talking about, it only it doesn't actually matter all the time, like for scalar operations is what they call an array languages, like when you are just adding a scalar to your matrix. Exactly. Yeah. It actually has, it has no, it makes no difference how you're, if you're storing it linearly in memory or structurally in memory, because if it's stored linearly, you're just basically doing a transform, a C++ stood transform on every single element. And so I just, I'm just, there's another aspect here, which is quite significant. When you're iterating through multidimensional data, you're usually either doing something element wise or the second case. And I'm going to, I'm just going to call it the second case for right now.
我们有matx，我们有（C++后端的Python前端，有点像numpy的拷贝），我一直想知道……比如，对于一种数组语言来说，什么才是真正最高效的后端？因为，你知道，你谈论的所有索引，它其实并不总是那么重要，比如对于标量操作，这就是他们所说的数组语言，就像你只是把一个标量加到你的矩阵上。完全正确。是的。实际上，如果你是线性存储在内存中还是结构化存储在内存中，这没有任何区别，因为如果是线性存储的，你基本上就是在对每一个元素执行一个变换，一个C++的std::transform。所以，我只是……这里还有另一个方面，非常重要。当你遍历多维数据时，你通常要么在做逐元素（element-wise）的事情，要么就是第二种情况。我现在要……我暂时把它叫做第二种情况。
Let's focus on that element wise case. That's, that's the case of like, you're adding a scaler to every element or, you know, you wanted to do something like a stood reduce on every element. That's something we talked about the last time. Now... Wait, pause. What do you mean by a stood reduce? Because assuming every element is like an integer, what does a reduction on a single integer do? I'm like,
让我们专注于逐元素的情况。那就是……就像你给每个元素加上一个标量，或者你想要在每个元素上做一些类似于std::reduce的事情。这是我们上次讨论过的事情。现在……等一下，暂停。你所说的std::reduce是什么意思？因为假设每个元素都像一个整数，对单个整数进行归约（reduction）会做什么？我像是……
if I have a multidimensional, if I have a 2d matrix and I want to sum up, you know, all of the, all, all of the elements of the matrix. Oh, so you mean,
如果我有一个多维的……如果我有一个2D矩阵，我想把矩阵的所有元素加起来。哦，所以你的意思是，
you mean regardless of the rank of your matrix, if you want to perform a reduction across every single rank down into a single scale or or or a count if if you want to count all the non-zeros in your matrix okay okay so basically any operation that yeah the structure the rank or the shape doesn't impact if you're reducing down to a single element or you're doing an element wise operation on every element okay gotcha and and importantly you know um importantly i think these operations they almost only make sense if they're all independent of each other like i can't you can imagine a stood reduce right being like that that being a useful thing like i want to sum up all of the values in this matrix or i want to count all the non-zeros in this matrix. How about adjacent difference?
你的意思是，无论你的矩阵的秩（rank）如何，如果你想在每一个秩上进行归约，将其归约到一个单一的标量，或者一个计数——如果你想计算矩阵中所有非零元素的数量。好吧，好吧。所以基本上任何操作……矩阵的结构、秩或形状都不会影响你是否要归约到一个单一元素，或者对每个元素执行逐元素操作。好吧，明白了。而且重要的是……重要的是，我认为这些操作几乎只有在它们彼此完全独立时才有意义。就像我……你可以想象一个std::reduce，对吧？那是一件有用的事情，比如我想把这个矩阵中的所有值加起来，或者我想计算这个矩阵中所有非零值的数量。相邻差分（adjacent difference）怎么样？
Yeah, basically you're saying you need a monoidal binary operation where you can do it in any order. Now, the reason that adjacent difference isn't a particularly useful operation to apply is because you you're you're taking the difference between you know two adjacent elements but what does adjacent here mean in this context right now and so so this first class of of things you'd of iterations you want to do something to every one of the elements and that thing is, you know, kind of independent of other elements and or at the very least it doesn't care about like position of one element relative to another. The key thing here, the key insight is these are operations on elements. The other class of things that you want to do to a matrix, I will posit, you don't really want to do them, you don't really need to consider multiple elements that have some relation to each
是的，基本上你是说你需要一个幺半群（monoidal）二元运算，你可以在任何顺序下进行。现在，相邻差分不是一个特别有用的应用操作的原因是，你……你是在求（你知道的）两个相邻元素之间的差，但“相邻”在这个上下文中此时意味着什么？所以……所以第一类你想做的迭代，你想对每一个元素做一些事情，而那件事（你知道的）在某种程度上是独立于其他元素的，或者至少它不关心一个元素相对于另一个元素的位置。这里的关键，关键的洞察是，这些是对元素的操作。你想要对矩阵做的另一类事情，我断言，你其实并不真的想做，你其实不需要考虑彼此之间有一些关系的多个元素，然后你就会关心索引，而不是特定的元素。所以，像这个例子，比如相邻差分，基本上对于一维情况，它是一个简单的，像模板（stencil）算子。但是任何做过任何数值编程的人都知道，如果我正在编写某种数值计算的模板循环，我想要……或者，你知道的，我想要能够做类似“IJ处的值 + (I+1)J处的值 + I(J-1)处的值”（诸如此类）的事情。现在，这里的区别在于第二类事情，你关心的是迭代索引。所以我断言，你可能想要对多维结构执行的两种不同迭代类别是：第一，逐元素，我的意思是，迭代所有元素；第二，某种你在索引空间中迭代而不是在特定元素上迭代的事情。所以，对于数组语言的听众，我可以给出几个翻译，即你的逐元素操作，我们会将其分为两个不同的类别。所以只有那些保持形状的操作，基本上就像数组语言中的归约版本，你会做的是，我们之前听到的词“raise”（提升），这是J语言术语，或者“ravel”（降维），这是APL语言术语。当你ravel一个有两个维度的矩阵时，形状长度为二，一个2x3的矩阵，当你ravel它时，据我所知，它实际上不会改变内存中的任何东西。
other, then you're going to care about indexes, not about the particular elements. And so, like the example of this, like, you know, adjacent difference is basically, for the 1D case, it's a simple, like like stencil operator. But anybody who's done any amount of like numerical programming knows that if I'm writing some sort of, you know, stencil loop that's doing some numeric computation, I want to, or, you know, I want to be able to do like the value at like IJ plus the value at, you know, I plus one J plus the value at I minus one J, you know, something like that. Now, the distinction here is in the second case of things, you care about iterating indexes. So I will posit that the two different categories of iteration that you might
它只是破坏了形状，因为无论如何一切都是以降维形式线性存储的。所以实际上，你可能认为是一个昂贵的操作的ravel，由于它们的存储方式，你基本上只需将形状更改为你的形状（你的维度）的所有元素的乘积，然后你实际上不需要改变内存中的任何东西。然后你执行一个归约。然后我认为当你提到索引时，我通常更多地想到子形状（sub shapes），但这是相同的想法，就像我在某个秩上执行某些事情，这等同于……你知道的，一个IJ索引。但是，所以……有没有关于……我刚才要说的点是，
want to do over a multidimensional structure is one, element-wise by that, I mean, iterating over all of the elements or two, something where you're iterating through an index space, not particular elements. So the couple translations that I would give for the array language listener is that you're sort of your element wise operations, we would separate into two different categories. So only the shape preserving ones that basically like the reduction version in an array language, what you would do is we heard the word raise earlier, which is the J term or ravel, which is the APL term, which when you ravel, say a matrix that has two dimensions, so a shape of length two, you know, a two by three matrix. When you ravel that, it actually, to my knowledge, doesn't change anything in memory.
在非常具体的C++空间中，我认为对于多维结构，你有两类有用的迭代器。第一类迭代器是一个给你值、但不告诉你这些东西住在什么索引处的迭代器。并且没有办法从中取出索引。但这没关系，因为你使用它的方式是对它的每个元素逐元素地做一些事情。然后还有第二类索引，它不是关于元素的索引。还有第二类迭代器，它不是关于元素的迭代器，不返回矩阵的元素，而是一个生成索引的迭代器，然后你可以用这些索引去索引矩阵。这里既有编程模型的差异，也有显著的性能差异，因为如果我们只需要构建高效的索引迭代器，
It just destroys the shape because everything's stored linearly in a raveled form anyway. So actually a ravel, which you might think is an expensive operation, the way that they're stored, you basically just change the shape to the product of all your elements of your shape, your dimensions, and then you don't actually have to change anything in memory. And then you perform a reduction. And then I think when you say indexes, I typically think more of like sub shapes, but it's the same ideas like where I'm, you know, performing something on a certain rank, um, that equates to just, uh, you know, an IJ index. Um, but so was there, was there a follow-up point to like, the point I was getting at is that
这比构建高效的元素迭代器要容易得多——从元素迭代器中我们可以恢复多维索引，这出于各种原因，这些原因与编译器向量化器的工作原理有关，我记不全所有的细节了，即使我能记住，也不会在这个播客中深入探讨，因为那即使对我们来说也很棘手。好吧，我有更多的问题，但我们要让布莱斯去锻炼和吃食物了。哦，还有两条评论，还有两条评论。哦，只有
in a very concrete C plus plus space, I think there are two categories of useful iterators that you would have to a multidimensional structure. The first category of iterator is an iterator that gives you values and does not tell you what index the things live at. And there is no way to get the index out from it. But that doesn't matter because the way that you want to use this is to do something element-wise to each one of the elements of it. And then there is a second class of index, which is not an index over elements. There's a second class of iterator, which is not an iterator over elements, returning you the elements of the matrix, but it's an iterator that produces indexes that you would then use to index into the matrix. And there is a both programming model difference here, and also a significant performance difference because if we only have to build efficient index iterators,
最后一条评论了。我们刚才在评论二。很快地，最后一条评论是对Kemanachi上一条评论的回复。Greg CPP回复了上一条评论中的一句话：“我认为一个出色的图表或动画视觉效果可能有助于在数组语言社区中澄清这一点。”Greg CPP对此做出了回复：是的，感叹号。我不是一个GPU程序员，但我真的很希望能有一个好的参考资料，来了解GPU编程在概念层面上是如何工作的，不是如何用CUDA或任何其他工具编程，而是它们
that's a much more tractable problem than building efficient element iterators from which we can recover the multidimensional index for a variety of reasons that have to do with how compiler vectorizers work that um i do not remember all the details of and even if i could would not get into in depth uh on this podcast because that would be that would be hairy even for us well i have more questions but we're gonna let bryce go exercise and eat food oh there were two more comments there were two more comments oh there was only
一般是如何工作的。例如，我相信大多数GPU都有一个CPU用户空间（引号）驱动程序、一个CPU内核空间驱动程序以及GPU本身上的代码，但我不知道每个驱动程序的职责是什么。例如，当你动态分配GPU内存时，分配算法在哪里运行？或者当厂商谈论GPU核心时，
one more comment we were at comment number two and very quickly the last comment was a response to the previous one by kemanachi greg cpp was responding to a sentence in the last comment which was i think a great diagram or animated visual might help clearing that up with the array language community. And Greg CPP responded to that. Yes, exclamation mark. I'm not a GPU programmer, but I would really appreciate a good reference for how GPU programming works at a conceptual level, not how to program in CUDA or with any other tools, but how they
这到底意味着什么？这能在几分钟内回答吗？好吧，我要倒着回答。所以GPU核心，通常作为一个营销术语，在NVIDIA GPU上，我们有一个实际的执行单元叫做SM（流式多处理器）。我认为这是最接近核心的类比。在GPU上，我们虚拟化了大量的线程，SM可以被大量超额订阅（oversubscribed）线程。事实上，这就是它们喜欢运作的方式，因为，你知道，GPU SM被指派工作的方式是，当它们在为一个线程组等待数据时，它们可以去为下一组线程执行计算。而且，你知道，这是高度流水线化的。所以，你知道，你想要做的是所谓的延迟隐藏（latency hiding），你永远不必真正等待某些东西，因为总有更多的工作可用。所以，你知道，你可能有一个活跃的线程组，然后你有……你知道的，30或60个——这些可能是稍微过多的数字——其他4个或16个线程组，你已经在它们上面发起加载（load）或存储（store），或者某些需要等待内存流量的操作。而且，你知道，那些是流水线化的。因此，当其中一个加载进来时，那个线程组就变得可用了。然后你去执行计算代码，直到
work generally. For example, I believe that most GPUs have a CPU user space, quote unquote, driver, a CPU kernel space driver, and code on the GPU proper, but I have no idea what the responsibilities of each are. For example, when you dynamically allocate GPU memory, where does the allocation algorithm run? Or when the vendors talk about GPU cores,
它遇到下一个内存加载。到那时，另一个人已经变得可用，可以开始计算了。所以它们是为这种桶形多线程（barrel threading）、这些SM核心设计的。我不记得那个问题的其余部分是什么了。看起来更像是……你知道的，对理解GPU计算模型基础知识的渴望，这也是我所渴望的，正如我们上次谈到的那样，我绝不是GPU专家。我要说的是，如果时间允许，我可能会放弃我的Array 2022主题演讲的原始计划，该计划本来只是回收我现有的关于C++标准并行的幻灯片的大部分内容。但我正在考虑放弃该计划，转而专门讨论
what does that really mean? Is that answerable in a couple minutes? Well, I'm going to work backwards. So GPU cores, like often as a marketing term, there is a, you know, on NVIDIA GPUs, we have an actual execution unit called an SM. And I think of that as being the closest analogy to a core. On GPUs, we virtualize a whole lot of threads and SMs can be heavily oversubscribed with threads. And in fact, that's how they like to operate because, you know, while the way that the GPU SMs are signed to work, while they are waiting for data for one, you know,
MD-SPAN，并更详细地讨论C++和编译器中与多维迭代相关的问题。然而，这需要……我和那个主题演讲开始之间的时间非常有限，而且由于我还有很多其他事情要做，时间更加有限。而且我有一个朋友要来镇上参观。好吧，我可以透露，汉（Han）下周要来参观。是的，我们会看看我是否有时间这样做。从技术上讲，我还有一份日常工作必须要做。
group of threads, they can go and execute for the next group of threads. And, you know, this is very heavily pipelined. So, you know, you want to do what's called latency hiding, where you never actually have to wait for something because there's always more work available. So, you know, you maybe have one group of active threads and then you have, you know, 30 or 60, um, and those may be slightly excessive numbers, um, you know, four or 16 other groups of threads, which, um, uh, you've initiated loads on or stores on, or some, some operation that needs to wait, um, on, um, memory traffic. Um, and, uh, you know, those are sort of pipelined. And so as one of those loads comes in, then that group of threads becomes available. And then you go and you execute the compute code until
我的意思是，你可以提出一个强有力的论点，即向数组语言和多维数组库的学术界发表关于多维迭代器和MD-SPAN的演讲可能具有巨大的价值，特别是如果你专注于它如何影响对GPU、对NVIDIA的编程。所以，你知道，这可以是你J工作的一部分。是的，是的，是的。但这需要比我可能有的时间更多的工作。所以我们走着瞧。走着瞧，如果你在接下来的24小时里收到我的一堆会议取消通知，那是因为我决定执行这个计划，并决定……我们将推迟所有会议直到……我假设你在对我说，而不是对听众说。不，我的意思是，一些听众……
it hits the next memory load. And then by that time, somebody else has become available to start computing. So they are sort of designed for this barrel threading, these SM cores. I don't remember what the rest of that question was. It seemed like it was more, you know, this plea for a desire to understand the basics of the GPU compute model, which is something that I too have a desire for, as we talked about in the last time, I'm by no means a GPU expert. I will say, time permitting, it is likely that I will scrap my original plan for my Array 2022 keynote, which was just to recycle a good chunk of my existing slide deck on C++ standard parallelism. But I'm thinking about just scrapping that plan and instead just solely talking about
它遇到了下一次内存加载。然后到那个时候，另一个人已经可以开始计算了。所以它们某种程度上就是为这种桶式多线程设计的，这些 SM 核心。我不记得那个问题的其余部分是什么了。它看起来更像是一个渴望理解 GPU 计算模型基础的诉求，正如我们上次所讨论的，我也非常渴望了解这一点，我绝不是一个 GPU 专家。不过我要说的是，如果时间允许，我很有可能会放弃我 2022 年 Array 主题演讲的原计划，那个计划原本只是重复利用我现有的关于 C++ 标准并行性的幻灯片。但我正在考虑放弃这个计划，转而专门讨论
MD-SPAN and talking in greater detail about the problems related to multidimensional iteration in C++ and in compilers. However, that will require... The time that I have between now and the start of that keynote is quite limited and made more limited by the fact that I have lots of other things going on. And I have a friend coming into town to visit. Well, I can say it's hot. Han is coming to visit next week. And yeah, we'll see whether I have time to do that. I do also technically have a day job where I have to do things.
MD-SPAN，并更详细地讨论 C++ 和编译器中与多维迭代相关的问题。然而，这需要……从现在到该主题演讲开始之间的时间非常有限，而且由于我还有很多其他事情要做，时间就更有限了。而且我有一个朋友要来镇上参观。嗯，我可以说是天气很热。汉下周要来参观。是的，我们会看看我是否有时间这样做。从技术上讲，我还有一份正职，我得处理各种事情。
I mean, you could make a strong argument that giving a talk about multidimensional iterators and MD-SPAN to the academic community of array language and multi-dimensional array libraries could be of immense value, especially if you're focusing on how it impacts programming to a GPU, to NVIDIA. So, you know, could be a part of your J job. Yeah, yeah, yeah. But it requires more work than I may have time to do. So we'll see. see we'll see if you get a bunch of meeting cancellation uh notices from me um in the next 24 hours it's because i've decided to execute on this and have decided that uh that uh we are postponing all meetings until post i assume you're talking to me and not the listener no i mean some of the listeners uh
我的意思是，你可以提出强有力的论点，向数组语言和多维数组库的学术界做一个关于多维迭代器和 MD-SPAN 的演讲，可能会具有巨大的价值，特别是如果你专注于它如何影响对 GPU、对 NVIDIA 的编程。所以，你知道，这可能是你正职的一部分。对，对，对。但这需要比我可能有的时间更多的工作。所以我们走着瞧。瞧瞧，如果你在接下来的 24 小时内收到我的一堆会议取消通知，那是因为我决定付诸行动，并决定……嗯……我们将把所有会议推迟到……我想你是在跟我说话，而不是在对听众说？不，我是指一些听众……
are on you know meetings that i would send to the cancellation notices for gotcha gotcha and if i send those meeting cancellation notices i'm gonna put in the note listen to as ads for details i mean this won't be out until after. Right. People will have to wait a week or two to find out why they didn't get to know. Listen to episode 82, which will be released on June 17th or something like that. All right. We'll wrap it up here.
你知道的，会议的取消通知我会发送……明白了，明白了。如果我发送了这些会议取消通知，我会在备注里写上：详情请听广告。我的意思是，这个要等节目播出后才会……对吧。大家得等上一两个星期才能知道为什么没能听到。去听第82期节目吧，该期节目将于6月17日左右发布，诸如此类。好了，我们今天就聊到这里。
Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听。希望你们喜欢，祝大家有个美好的一天。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。